[Musique]
tout mais j'ai eu le sentiment que les
gens de pousser à choisir entre deux qui
pourtant faisait et ont toujours fait
partie de ce que les gens ont du mal à
comprendre et qui est si évident pour
moi c'est qu'il y en a toujours un verre
c'est qu'il suffit simplement de
construire un pont entre ces deux mondes
du coup de mon père la famille et aux
écossaises et protestante
les grands parents sont des artistes qui
vivent dans une maison cossue de l'ouest
parisien
ils ont éduqué deux ans du côté de ma
mère est musulmane
mes grands parents sont des immigrés
algériens ayant réduit qu'est dix
enfants dans les corons du nord de la
france au grand paris était mineure
toute mon enfance j'ai passé une partie
de mes week-ends chez mon père dans le
16e arrondissement de paris
tout près de l'arc de triomphe et la
semaine chez ma mère dans un quartier
populaire du 19e ma chère place des
fêtes
depuis toute petite j'ai appris à passer
d'un monde à l'autre sans difficulté et
à assumer toutes mes appartenance à
l'adolescence
cette schizophrénie a commencé à être dû
ravir combien de fois ai-je eu la gorge
nouée en entendant mais deux mondes se
juger radicalement comme si l'un et
l'autre étaient complètement opposées
comme si il y avait un mur
d'incompréhension d'intolérance et
préjugés entre les deux comme si l'un et
l'autre essayé de me pousser à faire un
choix
ce fut en chemin complexe mais j'ai fini
par accepter cette vie de caméléon
notamment car j'en comprends désormais
la richesse c'est elle qui a dessiné ma
raison d'être refusé de faire un choix
et construire des ponts construire des
ponts entre des mondes qui a priori
n'ont rien à voir et qui pourrait
pourtant écrire ensemble comme mes
parents à l'époque les plus belles
histoires d'amour plus tard cette vie
quelque peu schizophrène a également
développé chez moi une vision du monde
plein d'empathie d'humilité et de
résilience
mais aussi une très grande sensibilité
aux signaux faibles et une inquiétude
grandissante pour notre planète
lorsque je vais me coucher le soir je
ferme les yeux et là je pense preuve
excite cambridge analytique à notre dame
des landes gilet jaune alexandre benalla
adama traoré great attenberg le petit
taylan jean luc mélenchon macron le pen
je viens j'étouffe en fait j'ai
l'impression que plus on avance plus on
pompe les ressources de la planète
ça nous savons tous mais pire encore
plus on pompe les espoirs des gens on
pompe on pompe ont jusqu'à ce que tout
s'effondre j'arrive donc à l'âge adulte
avec toutes ces inquiétudes en moi et
une conviction je dois faire quelque
chose et ça passera par le travail
la jeune diplômé d'école de commerce que
je suis devenu entre donc plein
d'ambition dans un grand groupe pour son
premier job est là bien là je me prends
un coup de poing claque sur la tête
je prends conscience que les grandes
entreprises sont bien plus concentré sur
leur bilan comptable que sur leurs
impacts sociaux ou environnementaux
si bien qu'elles font beaucoup plus
partie du problème que de la solution
encore une fois je me rends compte je me
je me retrouve coincé entre deux mondes
et encore une fois on me demande de
faire un choix ou bien je m'engage pour
le bien commun
j'agis pour changer la planète
ou bien je rentre dans une grande
entreprise pour faire de l'argent
ça y est j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont y
arriver que cette fois ci je vais devoir
construire un mur au lieu de construire
des ponts je vais le construire ce mur
un mur entre moi et moi un mur entre ce
que je suis ce que je pense mes valeurs
mes inquiétudes
est ce que je vais faire au quotidien
dans mon travail d'ailleurs ce mur
tout le monde semble m'encourager al
construire une fois l'inde maison que je
me dis avec toute la bienveillance et
l'amour imaginables évidemment ce saut
tu es la seule de mes neveux et nièces à
avoir eu son bac
alors t'as pas intérêt à les faire du
social tu vas faire de l'argent pensez
aux autres c'est bien mais d'abord tu
pense à toi mais ce mur je le refuse
je décide de rester dans ce monde des
grandes entreprises et je vais faire ce
que j'ai toujours fait
je vais construire un pont cette fois ce
pont se sera pas en pont entre deux
cultures deux réalités sociales ou même
de quartier mais bien en pont entre deux
enterrés que tout semble opposer
je vais construire un pont entre
l'intérêt business et l'intérêt
collectif
c'est alors que grâce à fanny eric et
vincent pro manager exceptionnel
je découvre les entrepreneurs et plus
particulièrement les entrepreneurs
sociaux les entrepreneurs sociaux sont
des personnes qui travaillent dans de
grandes entreprises et qui à un moment
donné de leur carrière se disent j'ai
besoin de plus de sens et ce sens je
vais aller le trouver en créant un
projet qui n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec mon métier avec ma fiche de poste
mais un projet dont j'ai eu l'idée un
projet qui était aligné à la stratégie
business de l'entreprise pour laquelle
je travaille et qui va venir apporter
une solution à un problème social ou
environnemental
je décide de tout plaquer pour aller
rencontrer ces entrepreneurs
je crée l'indra preneur chip tour le
premier tour du monde de
l'intrapreneuriat et de sao paulo à
détroit en passant par paris et
amsterdam
je rencontre 50 intrapreneurs sociaux
les interviews les films et je crée un
documentaire pour raconter leur histoire
rapidement je me rends compte que
discuter avec les ans ne permet de
conseiller les autres j'accompagne alors
un intrapreneurs puis deux puis trois
ces dernières années j'ai accompagné le
développement de dizaines
d'entrepreneurs et plus récemment avec
un binôme de choc et une équipe géniale
j'ai ouvert à madrid un accélérateur de
porteur de changement pour l'une des
plus grandes entreprises de l'industrie
aérospatiale coach
accompagnez au quotidien des
entrepreneurs m'a permis d'acquérir
trois certitudes que j'aimerais partager
avec vous aujourd'hui ma première
certitude c'est que changer le monde en
transformant l'entreprise de l'intérieur
c'est possible
ce n'est pas qu'un rêve c'est une
réalité et elle est déjà en marche
nous jeunes ou moins jeunes cadres
dynamiques récemment - récemment
diplômés nous avons le pouvoir de
transformer les grandes entreprises pour
qu'elles deviennent des entités qui
génère des profits raisonnables et
raisonnées en créant des impacts sociaux
ou environnementaux positifs
laissez moi vous raconter l'histoire de
nick nie qu'il y a quelques années
travaillées au kenya chez vodafone et il
a fait un constat celui que la majorité
des kenyans sont complètement exclues du
système bancaire
il fait également le constat que la
plupart d'entre eux ont un téléphone
portable
nick a alors l'idée l'intuition de
construire un pont entre ces deux
réalités de construire un pont entre ce
problème social qu'il a identifiés et
l'entreprise pour laquelle il travaille
il a l'idée de créer le premier service
de transactions bancaires via téléphone
mobile de vodafone qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui
m-pesa nick s'est battu pour faire en
sorte que cette idée devienne réalité il
est alors devenu entrepreneur et son
innovation et bien elle a changé la vie
de millions de kenyans et à la
transformer pour le meilleur
le positionnement de vodafone dans les
pays en développement
nick n'est pas
un cas isolé il ya aussi alice
intrapreneurs chez google qui a créé
google crisis response
pour faciliter l'accès à des données
critiques lors de crises telles que des
catastrophes naturelles ou des attentats
jean-marc intrapreneurs chez bell qui a
créé un nouveau canal de distribution
pour les produits la vache qui rit via
des vendeurs de rue en asie et myriam
qui a créé le premier tapis complètement
etc ont conçu des interfaces un tapis
fabriqué à partir de filets de pêche
polluants les ans les eaux des
philippines nick myriam jean-marc alice
ça pourrait être moi nick myriam
jean-marc alice ça pourrait être vous ma
deuxième conviction c'est que si nous
souhaitons transformer le monde en
transformant l'entreprise
nous avons besoin de nous réunir les
porteurs de changement que j'ai la
chance d'accompagner ne sont pas des
héros isolé ce sont des personnes qui
ont su trouver ce que j'aime appeler
leur tribu une tribu c'est un ensemble
de personnes qui ont les mêmes
convictions qui sont capables de voir la
bigger picture et qui sont prêtes à
sauter dans le vide radicalement et
ensemble pour transformer l'organisation
peu importe leur âge leur sexe leur
compétence leur métier leur niveau dans
la hiérarchie ou leur réputation
la seule chose qui compte et les réunit
et leur volonté d'agir ensemble pour le
bien commun elles existent votre tribu
prouver là et réunissez ou
ma troisième conviction c'est que c'est
en changeant les récits que nous
changerons le futur lorsque vous aurez
trouvé votre tribu imaginer rêver le
futur que vous souhaiter pour
l'entreprise pour laquelle vous
travaillez et écrivait le récit de cette
vision en écrivant de nouveaux récits
les porteurs de changement ouvre le
champ des possibles il crée un nouvel
espoir
ce récit diffusé le répéter le jusqu'à
ce que tout le monde l'adoptent jusqu'à
ce que tout le monde se l'approprient
jusqu'à ce qu'il la influencent les
comportements présent de tous vos
collègues
c'est en influençant les comportements
présent de nos collègues et de nos
concitoyens que nous parviendrons à
changer le futur
lorsqu'on regarde notre planète
lorsqu'on regarde notre pays lorsqu on
garde notre entreprise
ça donne le vertige
qu'est ce que vous vous ou moi pourrions
nous faire pour les transformer on est
trop petit pour agir bien cette
impression d'être trop petit d'être
complètement impuissant n'est qu'une
impression avec les entrepreneurs
j'ai appris que nous pouvions tous agir
de là où nous sommes
pour changer un peu le système est qu'à
force de gens qui construiront des ponts
un peu partout pour changer un peu le
système nous parviendrons à le changer
complètement
vous qui travaillait chez l'oréal vous
qui travaillait à la bnp
vous qui travaillait chez décathlon
imaginez si vous arriviez à braquer une
petite partie des ressources de votre
entreprise
aac et ses process pour construire un
projet auquel vous croyez profondément
un projet qui est qui va apporter une
valeur business à l'entreprise pour
laquelle vous travaillez en adressant un
problème social ou environnemental
ces grandes entreprises ont des
ressources financières gigantesques elle
touche tous les jours des millions de
consommateurs
imaginez l'impact que vous pourriez
avoir
nous avons choisi parfois par passion
parfois par nécessité d'entrer dans de
grandes entreprises
nous avons choisi de faire partie d'un
système qui ne fonctionne pas et qui
condamne notre avenir
soyons à l'aise avec ce choix soyons à
l'aise avec nos incohérences et
profitons-en avoir intégré le système
c'est avoir une place privilégiée pour
le faire changer de l'intérieur c'est
d'avoir une place privilégiée pour faire
en sorte que les grandes entreprises ne
fassent plus partie du problème mais
bien de la solution c'est avoir une
place privilégiée pour construire un
pont entre nos business nos entreprises
et les problèmes sociaux et
environnementaux qui nous asphyxie à
tous ceux qui travaillent dans de
grandes entreprises et qui ont cette
impression à l'intérieur de faire
avancer une machine qui nous emmène
droit dans le mur
réunissez vous errez écrivez l'histoire
si certains pensent que l'heure est à la
construction de murs notre futur dépend
de ce qu'ils sauront construire des
ponts
qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez merci
[Applaudissements]